recently there was a song that was
released by Jason Aldean he he had this
music video he put out there it's really
making the rounds and there's been a lot
of controversy surrounding it and the
song is called try that in a small town
and the whole purpose of the song is
basically to say if you're behaving in
the disrespectful ways which are
generally tolerated in large cities in
which we have been told as a population
for decades are morally acceptable
you're gonna have some trouble in a
small town so the lyrics are cuss out a
cop uh you know he's describing doing
things that are violent or unacceptable
and then he says try that in a small
town and see how far you make it down
the road we take care of our own here
you cross that line it won't take long
and you know find out or for you to find
out I recommend you don't try that in a
small town so this is a music video
where someone's essentially saying don't
come to our town and cause problems I
think it's a great message there are
people in the media who have literally
referred to this as a pro lynching
Anthem which is the most bizarre insane
and ridiculous stretch of an
interpretation I could possibly uh
imagine so this this idea that
traditionally American values are racist
that wanting to protect your community
and your town means that you're in favor
of lynching and that we need to abandon
our American values is so pervasive that
a song like this is criticized whereas
you have gangster rap which talks about
committing actual crimes and harming
innocent people and treating women
poorly and doing drugs in the media
never deprives that this it looks like
these lyrics could should have been had
the word if if you if you cuss out a cop
or spit in his face if you stomp on the
flag and light it up you're gonna pay
for it in a small town like but the way
it sounds stomp on the flag you know
cuss out a cop stomp on the flag you're
going to pay for it it doesn't it
doesn't like have the supposition uh so
people might be reading into it as if
he's telling people to do that I don't
think that's the problem if they're
upset he's saying don't do that because
gangster rap tells people to do horrible
things like that all the time and
there's never a controversy right I
think part of the problem is we live in
a culture where uh we're not expect
supposed to expect our neighbors to
share values with us we're supposed to
Live and Let Live and he used to love
that phrase when I was younger right
because like these libertarian ideals
and it's not that I don't know but I
think ultimately the fabric of our
society is strong when we have a
understanding of what is is acceptable
and what is not acceptable so the the
some of the stuff he's describing here
right like don't come to my town and
attack law enforcement and we can have
all kinds of debates about law
enforcement but we should all mutually
agree that we expect one another to
preserve our our safety right we don't
want that as a social contract to be
violated uh all of these ideas that he's
promoting are actually completely
reasonable it's just that he is
presenting them in a way that people
don't like and you're not supposed to
tell other people well you're not
supposed to do this this is against what
we're allowed to do we're supposed let
people Live and Let Live however they
see fit which is just toxic ultimately
we function the best when we are able to
say I know that my neighbor shares my
values and therefore will not look at me
and say well I'm allowed to do whatever
I want and I'm going to yeah so well I
want to ask Vivek what how how he he
feels about this and what your response
to this song has been and also just in
general the the denigration of American
values in a national identity and how
it's brought us to this point yeah so I
think there's The Superficial element of
this which
you know frankly others have covered
over the course of today as well which
is something I agree with I said it this
morning
is that anytime you have a song that
actually celebrates who we really are
something that a majority of Americans
by the way at least until very recently
the values enshrined in that song would
have United all Americans
that's actually what is subject to
censorship and cancellation when in fact
songs that glorify violence or
other kinds of undesirable Behavior are
the ones that we actually end up
culturally venerating so there's a bit
of a paradox there
I do think there's something deeper
going on and it ties to our earlier
conversation in the country
which is this idea of whether we believe
in concentric circles of loyalty or not
right the song was about a small town
and and I think that we were having a
discussion earlier about
the community I mean how do you take
care of your own yourself or your family
before you're solving
Global poverty in Ethiopia or whether
you're addressing the climate
and I think that that's one of the
questions we have to regain alignment on
I think it's an interesting question I'm
offering one view I'm clearly biased to
that view
but I think that there's a legitimate
question of saying that no no we don't
necessarily have to solve problems at
home before we solve solve them
somewhere else or do we actually take
care of the problems on our own Street
if you're try that in a small town it's
like almost I'm going to stand for my
people first I'm going to stand for my
family first I'm going to stand for my
town first I'm going to stand for my
nation first is that the right way to
think about our commitments or do we
have
transcendental commitments that go
beyond those traditional boundaries
somewhere else and I think that's in
many ways it's not a right or left
question it's an interesting question
to ponder and I think that that's part
of what's going on when we make up these
new abstract religions to substitute for
the hard thing which is look in the
mirror and ask myself who I am actually
do something kind for my parents or for
my family members or my neighbors
in some ways Ukraine has actually become
a substitute for this right I was great
as a substitute religion I mean if this
song was called try that in Ukraine I
don't think anyone would be complaining
about it exactly because what have we
tried in Ukraine and Russia you know on
one hand last year the thing that we
said cluster bombs that were going to be
war crimes or now the very things that
we will send over to Ukraine and so it
just becomes a the re-emergence of a new
kind of religion I'm going to have a new
one every couple years I mean a couple
years ago we were all posting black
squares and you know there's always a
symbol there's always something and it's
a test right do you comply can I give
you an outward symbol that I line up the
way that uh dominant culture wants me to
and I think that's why songs like this
are so interesting is because they make
people so I mean variety has this
article saying that it's the most
cynical song when really it's a call to
action and actual protection this is the
I mean like look if you want to argue
there's something wrong with the song I
think you're incorrect but this is the
most cynical song of all the songs of
all the songs on the radio this is the
most cynical you're out of your mind it
seems like a psychological I don't want
to be too like conspiracy but it seems
like a psychological operation with the
internet now we've got all the nations
of Earth influencing our nation we're
all influencing each other of course but
they're like overt applications to
corrupt and disband the United States
because it's the global leader and
who's who's making who's who's seeding
this this that that's a bad thing to
protect your neighbors who's who's doing
that is it the Chinese I don't want to
be crazy conspiracy because I don't know
but like who wants the U.S follow the
money I don't know but I I get a vibe
that this is not a natural phenomenon
from within our country the reaction to
this you is which yeah yeah you know
it's it's
plausible to me it's almost so bizarre
that that is a very fair question to ask
in some ways China is absolutely
responsible for a lot of this right
because China you know the game they
have played I'm gonna come back and say
that's not the entire explanation but I
think there's a lot of truth to it
though because China has played this
game on our culture for the last 20 some
odd years which is they want our psychic
insecurities to flourish they want us to
be psychologically insecure and here's
how they do it right the spread of
global capitalism in the 1990s was
actually their way of accomplishing this
where we fell into this trap that said
we were going to export Big Macs and
happy meals and western music was a big
part of this too to places like China to
spread democracy that was our vision of
democratic capitalism in the 1990s
bipartisan consensus by the way
Republicans and Democrats alike
what they realized is oh wait a minute
we can use these vehicles as a way to
actually spread our values back to them
we they thought they could use our money
to get them to be more like us China
says okay we're going to use access to
our Market to get America to be more
like us how did that work
what they basically said is you can't
enter the Chinese market be it a music
company a movie company Etc a lot of
entertainment fits this description you
can't enter Disney if it's this
description the NBA fits this
description you can't enter the Chinese
market
unless and until
you abide by the ccp's way of doing
things but we will roll out the red
carpet if you criticize the United
States yeah so this idea of
self-loathing of large companies
institutions entertainment institutions
in particular
relentlessly criticizing the United
States
while actually staying silent about the
actual human rights atrocities in places
like China that started in some ways as
a form of a psyop right by China on the
United States to say we're going to get
those institutions that you guys
venerate over there many of them are
companies or entertainment providers to
relentlessly criticize the us because
the more you do that while also staying
quiet and criticism on China the more
they're going to roll out the red carpet
for those companies and institutions to
be able to expand into the Chinese
market which means more money yeah so it
certainly there was a psyop component to
this but that trick only works
if we have a culture
that's still willing to buy up what
they're selling which goes back to that
earlier
absence of purpose and meaning and
identity in our culture yeah I think
you're absolutely right about the fact
that the the Chinese government has a
much better grasp on what is going to
tug at the heartstrings in what will
upset the sensibilities of the American
people as opposed to the American
people's understanding of what is going
to upset people in other nations or in
our own or in our own that's a very fair
point uh so one one story I usually
bring about the uh Biden Administration
with respect to how effective I think
he's been as a leader on the foreign
stage is he told this story in and again
this is him telling the story he thought
this made him look good the story was he
met with Vladimir Putin and he said to
Vladimir Putin I don't think you have a
soul man
and according to him Vladimir Putin
responded we understand each other okay
I hear this story and I go the president
of the United States just told a foreign
leader who was waging a war that he
thinks he's mean this is not going to
upset that foreign leader if this ever
even happened on the other hand what
does China do China tells the United
States of America that the United States
of America is racist and needs to
apologize for being racist despite the
fact that in order to Market a film in
China you have to reduce the size of
black characters on the poster China
doesn't care about racism but they know
that the United States has a high
prefixation on it so they try to
manipulate us with it and you touched
earlier uh turn our psychic insecurities
against us as Weapons back against us
and then they use capitalism as a
vehicle to enforce it exactly because
companies don't get to play ball in
China unless they actually carry out
that dictate it's just the game it's how
they play it and this is actually why
I've loved talking about the nine-lide
in relation to the Barbie movie I think
so many people are not aware of the
subtle games that China plays so having
this line on a map that probably a lot
of us students are used to seeing there
but as soon as someone in Vietnam says
hey by the way that's actually a claim
to land that belongs to us a bunch of
Americans suddenly have to go oh wait
I've never ever thought about anything
that affects you because I take the
information that has provided to me
without question and they have no
culture I mean there's a lot of reasons
why someone in America may not be aware
of the Territorial map of the South
China Sea on the other hand how
interesting that the Barbie movie is
suddenly this thing that calls attention
to the subtle uh claim from China to
this historical area yeah it's
fascinating you use the example of a
movie Top Gun the recent release of Top
Gun had a lot of those attributes to it
too
where I don't know if you guys noticed
but the
enemy was some nebulous vague Other
Nation we don't know who it is with snow
it yeah yeah and by the way
the old Top Gun the Maverick jacket that
had the Taiwan and the Japanese flag on
it
in the revised cut of the movie that had
disappeared in the original cut you know
it was actually real in the original
movie was actually original version yeah
there was actually identified animation
we're talking about the US and USSR an
actual rival here at some nebulous
Nation why is that
China's first read was that this movie
was too patriotic for the US to be
played in China so they come back and
make those concessions so part of that
that's that's micro that's at the at the
margin right well the Japan flag and the
Taiwan flag no longer show up it's a
nebulous alternative enemy arrival as
though it was disconnected with the
present reality in the United States
made it slightly less patriotic than it
otherwise was
is it any surprise that you then see the
same types of reactions from the same
movie industry associations or recording
industry associations that then are
engaged in self-flogging here in the
United States even as they will expand
into the Chinese market without a peep
so I do think that there is a cynical
Force at work here Ian I think you're
totally right about that
but I don't think it's the whole
explanation right that just amplifies
a deeper insecurity that still existed
in the first place thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time